I really want to just like get down
quickly and get loot if you want to do
that then we should go to a really
isolated place far away that way no one
else are driving yeah oh yeah all right
I'll find us a car while you guys to get
all the loot okay flush Factory would
that be out of the way enough I think
people are gonna go to that we should
probably try I bet no one's really gonna
go to Anarchy Akers you'd go there
alright let's do it alright like ten
people just jump towards anarchy a KERS
no sure yeah they did should we change
our trajectory no I'm gonna just do it
over here let's do it it's do or die I
love the way you'd go through this guy's
try and stick together and land so we
could fight as a unit you got it okay
I'm going right for the middle I think
the middle like where the Red Barn is
alright you get that red barn with the
red out terior the right of us yeah
they're going they're gonna land
northeast I'm going for the the the main
building
any luck fell into the building I found
a med pack is that good there's a
submachine gun no chest in here I got a
chest in an assault rifle good bid ammo
okay I heard oh that's Wade oh you got
the oh okay my [ __ ] area found a
shield as well yeah I'm doing pretty
good I got a blue something I found
there's two allies coming in the same
building all right I've got good guns
and a sniper okay I've got a submachine
gun in an assault rifle I got a good
combat shotty in an assault rifle all
right good news we're in the circle as
it stands right now okay I still have
consumption yeah sure let's go with that
one yeah that's a good one I'm gonna
give you a 30 to 40 years oh come on
dude what what teammate I just open a
chest there's teammate right over here
was like oh my god I think you I'll take
that hey [ __ ] I know that life whoa
we're 29 to 40 oh my god what happened
somebody got boned geez our team is
everyone sucking the big dick huh yeah
why don't we keep getting these teams
that uh get their ass kicked I'm gonna
go to the top of the hill on the south
side and see if I can perch up
I got a sniper so I'm gonna see if I can
do some damage we're gonna go over with
mark just like yeah I feel like we
should probably stick together I'm not
gonna go too far so I'm just gonna I'm
gonna be peeking so that I can kind of
get an idea of the lay of the land
I don't see much of anything going on
here all the fighting must have taken
place somewhere else all tomatoe towns
real close not that I can see from my
advantage
tomato town looks horrifying in low res
just building on the outskirts of town
down here to the east and enough
probably seen a whole lot of nobody I
don't know how much detail I can see
from this distance though so there's an
assault rifle down here if anyone needs
an assault rifle I'm good for now
there's a shotgun I just swapped out
mine for a green one
the chest nobody opened down here Wow
there was everything in that place give
me the shotgun ammo go good there was a
door right there whatever I like of the
way you think nobody open that oh you
guys are moving yeah cuz there's just
nothing here go team I don't know where
they're fighting are they coming over
from Pleasant Park or something cuz that
would make sense if that's where they
all like landed cuz the bus didn't cover
in that direction yeah whoo gunshots I
think that was our ally knocking someone
down whoa I see you guys I see boom got
him go good job are more two more to the
right two more to the right where how
far building I'm coming in I got a
couple hit I'm gonna start building
stairs there on those stairs you see
Adam got him got him gotten both there's
another guy that jumped off the the
thing further back like toward the water
well shots a yes shots from luck got it
god I took a hit but it's alright I'm
gonna I'm gonna build up some stairs
right here knocked one down there's one
like a lot more building over to the
Northwest Northwest
okay I'm not seeing it well shot coming
in behind me buy me buy me by do you
bind you [ __ ]
oh god damn it what the [ __ ]
wait if you can cycle back on us Wade
damn it how did he get both of us I
don't know
get him wait shooting wait good job
there's another one I think that that to
your left to your left to your left to
your left
oh yeah yeah
you're gonna got scissored it's fine
crime there's a lot of them what you
suck you suck the shotgun you missed me
three times player god dammit just next
teammate for God's sakes we're gonna get
a win I know we can get it with all
right where we going we go to retail
Road or Pleasant oh yeah we can do
retail yeah Oh see retail I'm jumping
early because I feel oh god I press that
forgive gun stupid we know I have I have
a friend SuperDuper close to me right
now
is it me is it a friend is it might be
me are you close to me right now yeah
I'm very close I'm a little in front of
you too that's that's not that's oh no
way that's not me no that's me I was I
don't know I don't know I see the guy
you talk you know it's not you all right
I'm gonna try to your friends I'm going
for the supermarket in the back back
left yeah okay I'll come that way I'm
going for the house next here by the
basketball court I have a revolver
okay guys submachine gun got a potion
man I'm finding all the potions great
I've got two revolvers all right I've
got an ally on the ground near me I
found bandages okay I didn't get a chest
but I got a lot I am a lot ammo a
legendary consumable is that the
celebrity bush oh yeah dude oh
definitely do it hello oh you had a bush
Yeti I'm a bush dude that's sick this
lasts forever
uh yeah it's like a it's like a
permanent thing I think you can turn it
up I think when you crouch you become a
bush right so how that works yes I don't
know I don't know it's something like
that wait I don't know all right I move
into the house is nearby yeah I got good
seems like no enemy presence as far as I
can tell
very little okay there's definitely woo
yes please there's a chest in this
building I hear it I'm gonna try and
steal your chest please do to see for
Stephanies little buildings before we
get our allies looting everything all
right cool so I'd actually even looked
like a real butcher is this just like
some stupid things good no no you do
like you become invisible when you have
that [ __ ] yeah if you stand still you
are no different than any other bush
I've never actually seen one of those in
person where yeah oh you're kind of far
away I'd like to see that
I got a bush you [ __ ] baby don't [ __ ]
baby I'm gonna just say right out and
that's a no no no are you oh god I would
never be able to tell I'm a bush a bush
a bush you know I'd screw you guys why
can't i HW bush what can I be a bush you
can't be a bush because you're not cool
enough okay you know I was thinking that
you didn't need to say out loud okay
moving UOB bushes next to each other
uh-huh you guys suck some dirt on my
[Laughter]
sweet bush
all right where are we moving to you
know what I think you have to do wait
every time you crouch and become
invisible what this every time every
time your your [ __ ] what was that what
why are there explosions I have no idea
okay honestly the bush is a little
obnoxious when you're trying to like see
whoa
that was nearby who the hell I think oh
there's a grenades being thrown to East
dude yes our teammate through this but
who's shooting on I don't understand
what's happening he's like shooting at
you me wait who Wade maybe you just saw
a bush and was like whoa bush a walking
bush what okay we got the collective
here I've got a bandage but that's about
it
I wish I was a bush guys lose weight
when you're crouched can you move Oh
someone's dancing okay why this is why
our team loses guys not the bushes and
those guys Boosh everyone's getting in
the booze oh you see someone it's just
like constantly shooting never played a
video game where you get a weapon wow
this is dangerous god I got a good guys
losers Tozzi bushwhack that rock Wow Wow
would you could you not what this
[ __ ] guy who's just shooting that's
that guy nothing come along with you
honestly I don't know I would thought
there would have been more enemies but
don't go in there alone just yet I've
got a teammate down here yeah but wait
up for us I don't I don't feel safe
letting anyone go on their own even if
it's like twos sorry I just worry I
worry wait oh you're good you're good
dad I understand I see stairs built
outside of it so it's probably been
looted Oh insect too
just gonna let me call you dead who'd
you call that it's a great pistol up you
know I'm good on weapons I'm just for a
mo you were like I worry and I was like
dead I understand like yeah yeah I see
nothing no things I see nothing my eyes
just suddenly stopped working all right
all right well I don't know where they
are but we wait wait
we the circle is on us let's go back
meet up with those guys who were on the
hill because if we all camp out there
that's a good hill because the circle is
also a little bit less obvious yeah well
yeah southwest of us no I those are
different guys that's a different group
I think so I think the main brunt of our
group is actually still by that hill
till we should like I see people jumping
north of us I think that might be a bad
guy north of us building directly north
behind behind okay all right I'm gonna
flank around this right side of the hill
here
yeah they're building there's definitely
our teammates there so should we build
or should we try to sneak this I only
saw one guy there soon they saw me they
saw okay go around the right side of the
the hill I'm flanking up I'm just a bush
I'm just a bush where the bush okay from
that building yeah wouldn't complex that
they were concerned I try to flank I can
come for a second I think he definitely
probably saw me I'm just to push
building stairs ignore me
ignore the push stairs missed him I am a
terrible shot apparently out to the left
running away building more yeah got him
or hit him I gotta hit on him - he's
running very quickly okay I'm not gonna
waste a.m. on he moved down to the left
into that compound yeah
hey nice bush man no it's broken tree
I'm a bush hey do I look inconspicuous
here yes extremely weight that the depot
is heavily fortified I don't like that
I'm gonna there's people all around
there I'm gonna start building up wave
teammates pushing up toward us this
appears to be the location of the final
showdown for I know some about final
showdowns this is a
predominantly it and guys I'm gonna
build some low walls I'm just a bush
hitting a tree with the pickaxe don't
worry about me all right building some
don't worry go over it go over it man
dude go over it over it dude stuck go
over it you stupid [ __ ] god damn it you
guys suck I'm just shots behind oh god
it's the guy again being an idiot just
shooting up in the air for no reason
how do I add a window hit G edit it put
a hole in the middle of it why did they
just throw a smoke grenade at me someone
got shot I'm not sure from oh they're
all over that roof there are guys
shooting for more like Northwest - yeah
he looks stupid you don't come on man
you look great okay I'm gonna try to
move
oh [ __ ] try to get this guy up come on
come on yeah that's all I see farther
and farther in okay I'll get him up you
build around No stop moving
oh god I'm like out of materials to
build with already knocked one out oh
come on don't why oh I just took away
the shield of one of these guys oh [ __ ]
they're attacking my stairs oh god
there's one on the right I just we've
got a lot of incoming no [ __ ] snacks God
get out of my way wait you oh you're so
far up okay wait I'm gonna try that down
in the open like that there I was
running down here try to get ammo
there's also a Gold sniper but I would
have been fired this idiot has done for
me okay no way Oh stupid wait I'm gonna
try to build walls in front of you okay
I'll just keep backing up just keep
backing up okay all right here we go
I will try I will try to help cover this
this is the wrong way oh my god I got
the wrong wall huh I'm bailing I'm
bailing I forget I had the wrong wall
queued up let me try and I feel safer
down here than I do back way up come
forward I'm coming around
okay I'm gonna build the tunnel walls
why my god why is it Oh the construction
materials not enough Jesus
I'm very low on materials distracting
them I'm gonna try and stick this on
stick this revive on Wade okay I think
we're have enough building up to to
throw them off yeah
are you should be good yeah you got any
less weight
I got heels if you bring them back to
this the the stairs area we need to like
move up though no we're doing good we're
picking them off we're actually at a
surplus right now I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go harvest trees get more supplies
oh god that wall is gonna yes I did
teammate tried to get it take the credit
for my word I'm trying to get materials
so that I can actually build up yeah I'm
like out of materials is there wait wait
wait Circle Circle Circle you're in the
circle wait
wait wait wait take these bandages all
right Wade crawl back to me crawl back
to me
you see where I am yeah I got you stupid
circle yeah we got the disadvantage but
it's right on them yeah but it's okay
because I think I think we're gonna
we've got the number advantage right now
where are these bandages I'm gonna I've
got when I drop them right here okay
with our friends it's 2112 but they're
pushing into that fortification gotcha
okay I'm moving up we've got guys in the
fortification there
yeah we're pushing up there's one on the
ground in this red building that I'm
running towards right yeah like all the
way all the way down
Gaucho [ __ ] hitting I hit something in
there it's 3:00 we're gonna win this
yeah I see it I see a lotta left there's
rocket launcher shoot him shoot you
shoot bub where's the one yeah I'm
officially out of ammo if you go to the
right there's a guy that I killed yeah
I'll go around to the right whoa damn
where are these [ __ ] are they
not a part of this I'm behind enemy
lines right now but there's only one
left
oh he's in here with me okay I only got
he's a bush he's a bush where you our
final enemies a bush guys I've got a
rocket launcher I'm coming Kay he's
wrapped right around this corner he's
right there oh he's upstairs with me oh
he's in the corner hi
I don't know it is stupid
which way we're behind you right behind
you that Bush in the corner it's UV that
bush get him there you go that was good
good one I know right it's fun when you
win and live
[Music]